you
[Music]
you
you
you
yeah hello and welcome to the Lee chess
titled arena number five I hope you all
made it alright to this stream I'm very
happy to be the official announcer for
this tournament so he just asked me to
do the commentary and I'm happy to do so
we are going to be on very shortly when
the tournament is going to be starting
very shortly I'm on the tournament page
is starting in five but this is very
loud isn't it how can I actually turn
this sound down and let me turn that
down a little bit it's a bit too loud
hope that's better yeah thanks a lot for
subscribing there was a subscribing
sound okay so that tournament
it's now on for the fifth time the first
four editions all have been won by
Magnus Carlsen and the various account
names I think the first one was not
doctor drunken Steen yet some other some
other account by the way I read the chat
I'm happy to to answer questions things
like that I'm always having an eye on
the chat I mean if it's really really
busy it can be difficult to read
absolutely everything but I'm trying
what is that
okay so we are ready to go in four
minutes this tournament who's come
actually the favor I mean definitely
Magnus is the favorite again but he had
huge issues in the fourth edition he was
behind the whole tournament and at times
for many points by many points behind
behind
Andrew Teng who's here on as penguin
penguin
I am one yeah complicated name he was
leading the whole tournament and Magnus
only caught him at the very end of the
event but we have tons of strong
grandmasters who can definitely put up a
fight
maybe not for first place but you never
know you also have to see that the
ratings sometimes not super precise for
some players if they are not regularly
playing bullet on your chairs or maybe
yeah simply rather inactive and
sometimes happen some should deactivate
the follow notifications yeah that's a
good thing but I'm not sure how to do it
maybe I can do this without sound yep
that would be probably a good idea let
me check maybe I can mute it somehow
really not sure how I see your point but
I don't see how
you know I don't know if you if I can
deactivate it now I don't see I don't
see how exactly I should deactivate it
sorry I don't know okay I would like to
switch the sound or four it may be but I
can deactivate it entirely I believe
that I can do it I really don't my dad
all that much um okay so we have I know
I can't deactivate it on streem labs but
I don't want to do that right now right
before the tournament is starting so we
are one minute a little bit yeah one
minute thirty yeah I can do it on to
swimlabs page but it's not I'm not a big
it still has the sound yeah this is
weird
[Music]
I have no I have no clue the sound and
the sound is on I have to activated the
tech sim um yeah there are still sounds
but I don't really see how to how to do
it I mean I can try to deactivate that
let me check
and I switched it I switched it off okay
so let's get going and I'm going to
start to watch a bit of Magnus but I
don't want to do it the whole time and
we have number one against number two at
the very very beginning so yeah hey
Magnus has taken only five and oh that's
a blunder but B seven is hanging or so
it's not like we have to be very
cordless so the sound let's sue the
sound I don't know where it is coming
from I've switched it off I don't know I
absolutely don't know where this is
coming from okay so let's see this game
yeah magnesium is our pond and a couple
of seconds which is also quite worth
something in this scenario it's bullet
without any increment which is a
difference to some other some other
websites and and events for example the
the chess or comma vents they are with
incremented Isis with our increment yeah
here the a pawn will be very dangerous
the night is kind of offside on f3 and
it looks like the a pawn should should
win the game preserves the bishop and
yeah white should should win this
endgame the best that black can hope for
is to defend defend with against rook
and rook and Bishop no I'm not playing
I'm doing the official commentary here
for leeches and it's better to yeah
focus on the top level games oh that was
a big one what
mangers do their so this is probably
probably going to be ending in a draw
let's see what night king is doing it's
a very strong display of bortnik he's so
just wow that was really a bad game of
Magnus maybe he can save the draw that
he should should win on time
you shouldn't win on time here Oh Queen
could have been taken but there's all
pre-move Oh Oh Magnus was very slow at
the end so that there was a bad start so
I'm going to stick with them fold in a
while and then see that we also look at
some other games but he definitely has
to do a better job than in the very
first game
yeah here we've got the Kings Indian
exchange and what's happening here okay
no is plain I'm just kidding huh Magnus
Sims says that he hasn't played any
bullet since the last Reno okay we'll
see what happens bullet is a lot about
yeah practice and at having a flow yeah
here he's upon down but should get one
pawn back on b2 and black has some some
activity with the rook so he's maybe a
little bit for choice but it's not
something that should you know white
blundered the pawn basically it's still
not something that should necessarily
win but it's definitely annoying for
wide to defend in a in a bullet scenario
I think the sounds are also gone now
yeah let's see if Magnus can convert
this what he definitely wants if
possible is some passer on the King side
maybe with h4 and aged three he can do
something and now wide allowed him to
activate the King that should be winning
for black now check on the second
probably and yeah black eyelids even
valium it's going to now promote one of
the pawns and there is no there's no
defense in terms of stalemates or
anything yeah we've got the Queen and
black one so a win in the second round
for for Magnus now the early loss gets
to some pairings that people really
would really like to get you know
you don't play magnets later in the
tournament I mean he will definitely
catch up to the top but it might take
take him take a while if the other guys
at the very top continue to win
so here white is also in good shape
Black's Knight only eight in particular
is very bad and I'll see five is a
strong move black Bishop c4 looks like
that now come very naturally is also
nice wins the Queen you got the sounds
again no clue I thought I'd switched it
off but anyway yeah in black black
resigned
I don't watch Gordon Ramsay that's a
cooking show right I don't watch any TV
so definitely I know okay well master
Baba Ramdev I don't know who that is
from the US okay so we have a Sicilian
type of position here and I think black
tries to get initiative on the Kings
side looks quite nice now maybe using
the G foul yeah but white is extremely
solid so it doesn't look like it is so
dangerous taking on their four losses to
Queen g7 now I think yeah sure should
not work at least you gave me you can
take on g4 and sacrifice on g4 yeah it
does work it seems Queen h4 is winning
can you to look g2 and black wins the
Queen
okay and now okay after the the the
rooks all of a sudden get extremely
active that was really weird
and now this is dropping the Heydrich
but I didn't see what Magnus could do
about it that's a very weird game okay
this is at least a draw but white can of
cause and should probably avoid to draw
yeah white white should win well it's so
so tricky now the king is super safe and
the knight on f3 is such a monster it
prevents all the checks covers
everything yeah why it should win not
easy not is that often Magnus it looked
like a win but all of a sudden thinks
things dropped yeah so let's see
Grandmaster Rainman what is happening
here Magnus has to get some wins in in
in one row and then you would also get
those bonus points what happens here
why didn't move okay
[Laughter]
yeah maybe you need some Nathan needs a
B or something
yeah I'm still following him if we we
jump back here let's see we don't have
to watch him the whole time let's let's
see what penguin Jam is doing is also
extremely strong in bullet is playing
Knight Kim currently they are both
ranked number three and number four so
what is this position like we have to
adjust here it's like materials equal
but why it has a really nice attack
going on the kingside so I think white
should be four choice in this position
now let's see what what happens Knight
age four Knight f5 is definitely an idea
but e5 is under pressure so the bishop
is first approved this is a very nice
looking maneuver yeah and White has the
better ending and themes a manga Scott
connection issues that that's possible
of course so let's see what what happens
here very dangerous for the black King
but it seems like there is no immediate
issue there should be five mate is the
threat but there are checks and the
exchange got lost but white will win
this on time for sure yeah very very
quickly played by penguin now playing
arc of fifty who is arc of fifty
Switzerland
Tomic world champion I don't see the
name okay so what's going on here
and I've got an equal material position
but right before I think was a strong
move that's black somehow did not play
jumping into d3 was strong I mean black
black that's made mate on g2 what's
going on here hello am I blind
hey what's going on here there was made
on g2 more than once kind of kind of
stunts that that that they don't make
them that they don't play the made me
black is winning anyway but may dismayed
is made I'm kind of doubting myself like
what they doing ok this was also very
clean win by a black I mean main made
this made is made wgm cookus who is that
oops I'm sorry about that like to learn
who that is
Peter pop from Hungary yeah okay yeah
very nice position here for white and
Bishop g5 now would be a problem
okay f6 is still a move so it's not
clear that this is extremely strong oh
it actually isn't yeah in this
particular move order no this is nothing
much probably f4 to keep the e5 pawn
yeah yeah d4 will probably m4 but good
play good play by black
yeah but what is quite no I don't really
think it's impolite for title players
not to give their real names in their
profile I'm not sure why they why they
should shouldn't need to do it it's not
that I mean on some service the target
players given free accounts and for
example in the internet chess club or
the ICC there's a title player you get I
mean I am at higher you get a free
account but you are supposed to or you
have to not supposed to you have to give
your name in the profile but I kind of
understand that because they kind of
feel like aiming more title players it's
beneficial for their membership count
and they want their one the names in
there but as leaches is free anyway like
it's by the way extremely is extremely
quick and white is winning now but it's
not going to be enough on time wow it's
not losing this on time this is crazy
how many moves does he play penguin and
he won on time what this is crazy this
is completely crazy how is that possible
wow I mean I know I am really slow but
that was like speed demon I mean crazy
quick yeah this is a very nice position
by by white him or for white blacks
Kings Indian here was really really
terribly played yeah that that was a
slight progress for black but it's still
it's still pretty terrible White has a
clear advantage in space the only issue
is yeah sheesh
probably prevented this interesting yeah
black is able to put very strong very
strong peace positions up only 5g5 and
even the rock on b6 as having having
some kind of influence now nicely done
by black he was completely toast out of
the opening and now he's maybe winning
it looks quite terrible see a3 is
falling and the attack of the Knights
combined with the rook on d6 will be
probably winning the question is the
Queen's in the defense blacks best try
against e4 and I don't know you can play
many openings of course that it's it's
more about what is best for you then
some objective evaluation is to see does
he survive that it looks really really
difficult okay now the Queen if black
does not find a mate here penguin will
win somehow somehow it didn't do a god
Wow can he win this I cannot believe
what he's doing with the pre moves yeah
so black one time there wasn't up and
down an up and down game I'm going to
uncheck them the standings and see if
Magnus is catching up probably probably
not he had some connection issues so who
else is on I mean there are a couple of
really really strong players maybe let's
watch somebody somebody else for the
following an alley reason that is a very
strong junior player from Iran Ali Riza
future and probably completely killing
that pronunciation is a very promising
junior player as you see 2003 is
probably the year yeah but I mean yeah
in this position black is the exchange
up but the a pawn is extremely dangerous
I mean that can absolutely never lose
but it's not easy to win probably it is
winning because g2 will form he has to
sacrifice now as 97 was threatened and
now this should be a win for black the
king of porn ending is a win
dari RZA will easily checkmate with the
widow with the Queen now and we have
made here against kudos that was Pete
wrapped up very strong also yeah thanks
for the message in the chat some people
and they watched my videos for four
years thanks a lot yeah this year it
will be seven years since the channel
started I didn't go on watch right yeah
so next kami about Ali Riza he's
currently in fifth place so close to the
top and MSB to I don't know who that is
would be nice to have that here but it's
not in that preview yeah here the check
is giving us netting who that Queen has
very little very little squares but
white is dropping the Queen over that
was a there was an easy one it was
against the fourth place so but as we
have seen even though the absolute best
players in the
tournaments they have the odd bad game
playing against operas that
international master I think Vincent
what who is as they told me Vincent is I
think inactive in in over the board
chess I've played them a plate of a
tournament chess some years ago that was
my most beautiful whenever against
operation absolutely the most and is the
most the most spectacular win was
against the black player and scam okay
so here ali reza has them it's the
better position i cannot post a link to
to my to my game there it was played in
a in a local league game so it is not on
any major database and it's owned in my
personal database let's say I once made
a video on it on on Kings crushers
channel a long time ago yeah why does
here clearly better with the pin on on
e6 and difficult for black to to defend
his position I don't really see how the
night only six is hanging Bishop f5 is a
threat rookie aides okay that's a good
try you know h7
and then the light squares I extremely
weak queen g6 probably no okay yeah
white also has the clear clearly better
time MSB to is blue bomb okay that fits
yeah that fits
yeah I'm going to follow Magnus again a
little bit but I don't want to do it the
whole time so I just learned that he's
like in the forties here 40th place here
24 now so let's have a look
playing Baba Ramdev
we had him earlier on the stream and
magnesium is in an equal ish position
knight c6 s now the threat maybe white
is a little bit for choice due to the
activity on the C file it can be the
slightly better ending here for white
maybe well f7 itself falling right but
there is count to play a little bit for
black yeah will seem Magnus is going to
be able to convert it yeah no I'm going
to take bets that he is that should be
that should be working no self made that
we have a through gauge one or something
yeah okay three extra points and he's
got six extra seconds but I kind of feel
as somebody mentioned in the shadows got
connection issues it doesn't feel so
flew and game is very quick usually and
this feels a little bit yeah a little
bit less convincing connection issues
however can be really terrible in in all
actions in general but in in bullet in
particular
this is also a general problem for the
typical for those standard stalemate it
says it's a bit of a problem for the
online tournaments that they're now with
money and so on if you lose your
connection or your connection is really
bad then you have problems they are
simpler okay so that kind of a weird
opening by both players especially by
black so Magnus will definitely catch up
to the top unless the connection gets
worse which can be the end of any any
aspirations of course so here here the
the weakness only six is a big issue at
some point white will probably put a
piece on e6 and simply open the position
up yeah like here just open it up even
if it costs a pawn and here sacrifices
on e5 look he probably not super
convincing to be honest but should be
five was not a convincing win he is just
doing it slowly but surely double on the
F file maybe okay no it's going for the
trade of the bishop that also looks very
strong and it's very strong white is
definitely winning but he's not playing
quickly and he the time is ticking down
yeah that will be difficult tournament
for Magnus if the connectionism is
really that problematic and the time is
extremely important of course in those
in those events and if you are down on
your own problems so more time very
difficult yeah here Bishop g7 wins
material and he played it still not
so easily converted and now that should
win with somebody six yeah but you're
not going to mate and the time is an
issue a huge problem that's bad that's
not good yeah like now is for choice
blacks pieces coordinate very well the
points are rolling and Magnus has no
time on the clock have to when winning
yeah not easy at all but it felt weird
yeah it was very very slow ish at some
point yeah you you cannot overcome that
if your connection is totally I'm
tempering you you can play on any given
level that it's not enough so here he's
going for four pills defense or modern
defense
yeah it's probably not winning the
tournament that's very much very much
possible if you have this kind of
problems hard to overcome age six year
was hanging wasn't taken by white for
some reason yeah maybe the connection
gets better
makini can definitely we can definitely
overcome some some points behind but
it's not going to be all that easy this
is also not a game that black should win
I mean draw maybe but winning seems very
difficult no no if I the son
you know black can try on the dark
squares but he should normally speaking
not win maybe maybe there is some
between g3 now black wins on this
probably could win as well no I'm sure
it should be a draw if white just puts
the bishop on the long diagonal and
waits should should be very dry where
was the weird decision so he is winning
it position wise at least at two seconds
yeah Cooper's lost some time
I gave Maya
24th place hey jerk is a very strong
player and not even better put it it
shows how strong this strong this event
is yeah I've got a Catalan type of
position where white I think should be
better
White's pieces are a lot more active and
he's got potentially even a tech on the
King tactic who asked why isn't Tang
streaming hmm well if you want to win
$3,000 you probably should try to really
do all the best you can and he's got
very good chances if I don't think that
any of the other guys can can put up a
real real fight I mean maybe Magnus can
pull a comeback but I don't think any of
the others can do it we'll see but I
think it's I think it's difficult this
is also a game that Magnus should not
win he's got the time advantage but
yeah I think cows emplaced is
exclusively for the fun of it he
absolutely does not care about the first
price like the money connected to the
first price I mean in Norway you can
look up what people earn I mean they
have a public record for that and this
is what Magnus owns in a couple of hours
per day earns in a couple of hours per
day the 3,000 just by being him
basically so he doesn't care anyone that
came I think he likes to win because he
likes to win but not because he needs
the money so what do we have here b3 g3
stuff white is definitely in good shape
here
[Music]
how am I going to stream regularly again
I have to have to say have to check it
yeah because the streams that I did in
the first couple of months this this
year they were all too late during the
day German time it was in the night time
usually and and it was too late for me
my serum got completely down the drain
my camera is aimed too high you should
use the rule of thirds okay I think I
can adjust the camera maybe
better okay so Magnus has won a couple
of games he is getting getting closer
catching here catching is really doing
what is the rule of thirds I have no
idea what the rule of thirds is in the
in the first place I cannot tell you
so here black is black is in good shape
he's got to see far white is no attack
and Bishop before now is an idea or
Bishop III looks pretty awful by the way
I turned off all the notifications here
because it sounded like it is it is
annoying so if you I don't even see the
donations if you don't need anything I'm
Razoo per happy if you do but I don't
see it currently so so here Magnus is up
a queen right fearlessly going to e5
Luke g6 king e5 can you do that
it's not made what's going on here isn't
that even so clear Oh is there the king
only five looks looks difficult to
handle okay this is a kind of position
where I probably would get shake me that
yeah by some silly thing
and so Magnus has done it of course he 5
now is a little idea that you should be
aware of and he's just sending the deep
horn down the board yeah and Queen d2
will pick up the rook yeah very nice job
and he won this game so let's have a
look at the standings
so penguin is leading with 50 points how
many points Magnus is 16 behind this is
not so much it's not so much at all so
I'm going to watch a bit of penguin and
see what what he is doing
yeah it's got a very nice positioning
against a nation
I am engine nation f3 now is an idea and
it was picking up a piece White's King
has a little bit out in the open but
he's got so many so many pieces around
it so that it doesn't matter the Queen
probably has to go all the way back and
now Bishop f6 TM this is going to be a
dangerous attack on blacks King actually
yeah Queen TX h5 now is an idea I had
imagination that's the last one yeah I
didn't didn't catch that one at first I
am a nation is imagination true
so who's checkmating who he that set
looks super crazy
queena three mate is a threat but white
comes first Group G 122 mate
no mate now very nicely done and mate
woo very good job by penguin
he's crazy crazy quick yeah Magnus
doesn't have world champion as a title I
would be a cool to have you right but
it's not really a title as the as the
other one song I mean they they take the
titles that are given by the video or by
national federations the World
Championship title technically it's not
such a title for example and it's not
something you get for for your whole
life it's temporary
okay so let's see what happens here
black is a pawn down penguin but it's
got a good position gak was asked he
bought both of my chest but books
they're actually three for what rating
did you mean them to be that's difficult
the English opening is meant for a
reasonably high level I don't quite
remember what we put what we put in the
in the description on chasuble I think
like 1800 plus would be reasonable the
Banco is also rather do more of a
difficult one but this I think also
could be played by lower rated players
the e for repertoire is basically it can
be used by basically anybody I think
even though you can argue
what your level should be until you need
some kind of opening advice okay let's
look at this penguin here it's down upon
but the f-pawn is somewhat dangerous
however white has b-pawn night Andrew
here in the attack against the king so
this is a very yeah how do you call it
scrappy kind of position where you
anything can happen I believe King is on
the edge of the board oh that was a very
unlucky moment for a white yeah black
black should win now penguin should but
the a bonus is the only pawn that he's
got left and well the time is really
really bad time situation and that is
except it's all pre move now they are
white will probably win it no women
candidate master
there are several females with 1100 feet
and have the WCM title yeah this is true
but the the WCM title or the the CM
title also the the general CM title or
not the w CM title they are also wanted
for accomplishments in union
competitions and this is something that
it's not dependent on rating so those
people who got those those are
youngsters who won like the underage
championships or continent or something
you can argue about that but I think
it's okay if they give out title to to
award that somehow yeah here penguin
should just wins his upper material and
black is simply not moving okay it's not
very fair
that's not very fair
I mean he's screwing up his own chances
but also of the one who was ahead
that's not very young very sportsman
like okay so next game for penguin I'm
going back to cars and I obvious that's
a cool opponent so let's see how it's
doing there if I think it's crazy if you
I don't know you don't quite see it in
the stream I can they have played more
than three more than 500 games already
only chest and penguin is sitting were
332 roughly 200 ok so here white has a
nice position g4 as a cool movie is
opening up the kingside maybe giving up
the g4 pawn for opening up of lines
operation did not react to eight it
already this is like completely lost
yeah white has a completely winning
position here
he's got the attack and even the pawn to
boot though he doesn't have a pawn I'm
sorry
hey White has a huge attack Jeep the GFL
and I cannot believe that black you
should be able to save that Bishop g7
should win which is seven now there are
threats one to h7 that's just queen h7
it's a nice mate queen 87 okay that wins
as well but Queen f7 was made into as
well okay
so cool penguin is so leading his Magnus
on the first page already I don't think
he is right he isn't ali riza no
actually leading it's one of the
favorites yeah I think so where is
Magnus he's still sitting here he lost
game so difficult if he's not catching
up quickly playing against the number
five and his position is tough
they'd be tough to explain it's very
weird White has huge compensation here
for what for pawn
it's a pawn but White's position should
be fantastic him so what about the b7
pawn the seven-night or he's getting one
back he definitely can win it but it's
it's a matter of time if you cannot if
you are ever if you have an unreliable
connection it will be very difficult to
overcome so yeah that that ending should
win yeah now it is so if you get if you
get the C pawn it's easy it will be
eight coming
FM Hawk 20 M on those roughly 20th place
still very strong bullet players I mean
he is lot more lost more than 100 points
in the first 40 minutes of this event
which shows that he that he is
struggling you know this looks like a
good position for Black Knight comes to
the forward temple and now there is some
in d3 every this week
yeah black should hey white actually
resigned and that's early but black is
completely winning has got 12 extra
second so that some who is serious a
meal chess grandmaster G C meal Agra
Molly F I don't know him sorry yeah
roughly equal position here that one
sorry yeah this is a roughly equal
position but White has some gotten some
some pieces near the King and now it is
still it is still roughly equal wide
it's got the more active pieces rook
cannot go to the one that's very
important so black will get the D file
and now black is probably better and has
won a pawn on a form rookie one yeah
threatening made on e one yeah ok
Carlton is clearly on top in this game
yeah wide resigned early resignation see
this is definitely helpful yeah if you
don't have to play out all those all
those positions so Magnus is catching up
a little bit getting to 12 place it's of
course very essential that he gets a
string of wins and then I get so streak
points so English opening here by white
please lower set up probably going for
before break which now happened yeah
this very close positions they are not
going to be decided quickly 94 I didn't
do it one more layer it was already
decisive I think for move earlier and
I'd have 6 check this is the mother of
all folks black can safely resign him
a Jade and 906 skilling you know Dwight
wins everything
Oh interesting him Queeny aid was also
decisive of course yeah it wasn't even
the best there technically speaking but
what is totally winning
95 him yeah that's definitely true the
the message in the chat that Magnus
needs to win against the leaders and
that will happen if it will happen I
don't know but winning against the
leaders in the tournament will stop them
streaks and extend his own streak which
will be essential of course yeah this is
a completely winning ending with two
extra pawns still this is taking a lot
longer than it needed to take wasn't the
absolute best technical plane yeah but
now the F corn is doing the job f5 f6 f7
you cannot stop it I can just okay we
can win drew okay so another another win
yet by Magnus so it's got a couple of
wins in a row and is on the first page
so it's on page 7 and he's 20 points
behind Razer yeah I'm going to watch him
a little bit and see how the tournament
leader is doing playing here against
Michael pause okay
very strong very strong Grandmaster in
over the broad chest 2,700 for a long
time here where who is the as an
exchange up and it's also up a pawn it
looks very good white should win this
but okay blacks position is so somewhat
tricky sometimes ideas with Bishop f4
like now pieces are reasonably active
and the rooks
I'm not currently doing that much it's
still tough it's still tough to win in
this kind of bullet setting so raised is
good doing a good defensive job
yeah rooks III now maybe uh-huh
doesn't do it yeah maybe has to watch
for the a pawn that's possible I think
white is not playing quickly enough
those three four seconds difference can
now the rook has been blundered or the
exchange ultimate a new cache works
between age fourteen age who I expect
it's there an issue
uh-huh oh I was a there wasn't a
connection program black lost on time at
the end timed out so let's hope that
connection issues are not deciding this
event yeah thing is fifteen is one of
the youngest grandmasters in the world
Kings Indian set up by black play
against Astra ma Murray
well pretty even position I would assume
with the Queen's traded but I think
black is quite active an idea that comes
to my tias age five and Bishop to age
six okay not anymore
but what black wants to do is some
that's a we had moved to five weakening
the light squares a lot white should
play g4 and 93 to f5 and just be better
yeah good job by white I think he has
gotten a pretty nice advantage
this game
nicely done
very nice game but what black is
completely completely outplayed here in
this game it just the rukon f5 is kind
of kind of funny oh and now there is
counter play and mate yeah that kind of
black was completely completely
outplayed but white stumbled into a
checkmate yeah that could have been me
on the white side doing reasonably well
and then then playing something totally
stupid
okay so we have okay
black blundered upon here early on with
the Bishop e7 tactic but again bullet
shells upon is not super important oh
there was a master yeah black wins yeah
this is how you can win as well yeah
checkmate opponent blunders queens and
so on it's all part of it those those
who wins and importantly don't do it
yourself don't give away those easy
points so against imagination why does
going form the smaller brother slowish
set up the color system but it's easy to
play you can make quick moves without
getting into any trouble this is really
important sometimes to just being able
to dash out quick moves here white has
does he have the better ending yeah I
guess he does know the knight would have
a good spot on c6 very likely okay
doesn't happen yeah white I don't know
maybe he should have
maybe you should have not played like
that no he's evil is quite young it's
not a wrong
the-the-the the years is correct in the
in the account name but he is a trouble
really in trouble okay white has gained
a lot yeah but getting the getting the
deep on yeah tough it's still tough luck
has to move the bishop we doesn't Wow
there are tons of really really hard
Mouse lips coming now okay
don't see that too often for the guy's
own at the top okay so what's happening
here Magnus on six plays he's slowly is
slowly getting them Baba Ramdev really
has a winning streak
yeah we can have a quick look what he's
doing
I ain't playing on ERISA so we would
have had this game anyhow I know I don't
think you maintain the streak with the
draw you have to absolutely win I think
I think I'm not a super not an expert in
that net field yeah here black is in
good shape
absolutely I think I think he's got all
that space gained and okay the Queen
side is six chick
so black is a Pisa
oh yeah I don't know some people really
really want to get banned anyhow what's
going on here yeah White has wriggled
himself out of everything and is winning
mate Wow okay yeah very very fighting
kind of fighting is wrong and I'm liking
the Redwood here like up and down
struggles and it's more like yeah people
are going like yeah look that okay
he's playing Baba Ramdev explain ARCA 50
now
yeah here black is definitely okay
probably quite equal with this position
I've got penguin playing Magnus yeah I
don't want to I want to watch that to be
honest so penny penguin is white and we
have a complicated position here with
basically everything on the board this
is a really big one yeah Magnus has to
win this if he wants to get anywhere and
this in this event position is probably
better for white but it's quite quite a
messy position you know I think the last
couple of moves were rather in favor of
Magnus here with black White's King is a
little bit weaker and yeah I think maybe
objectively white is better but I think
it's easier to play black in this
scenario we are ever I have some watts
actually for the channel but I don't
think they around this is the thing it's
kind of unusual usually somebody is
around yeah now white is better g7 is is
weak and I think yeah here Queen g7 was
even a threat like Queen fo Queen a for
a queen e3 mate oops he definitely he
almost certainly over looked at and now
Queen g7 made us on the cards
Queen age 8 King G sex snow made ice
bringing the King to h5 this is crazy oh
that was a blunder and now it's all
about the time but penguin is so quick I
cannot believe that magnets can pull
that off yeah
penguin windirstat so very it was a very
important one ya know wow there was a
very tough game okay I'm going to watch
a bit of Magnus now if he can oops that
was not what I wanted to do sorry that
was a very tough game I mean it's it's
still not decisive we are at there's
still one hour left so Magnus is playing
Baba Ramdev yeah
Magnus is a winning position yet it's so
weak on the dark squares that he is that
he should win this
why does a pawn up and the bishop am and
now defiled it's actually very
instructive
the knight is now completely dominated
the only way for it to be better is to
come to e5 but that takes a long time
and white white should win still be
seven is 56 this week black cannot cover
the points as I resigned important win
near fall for the world champion to be
somewhat somewhat in the hunt in the
hunt not the hunt okay
against kill Maya going for some and
this seems to be one of the blitz lines
that were bullet lines that Carson has
in store this f59 h6 business yeah
that's weird right but in bullet chest
you can do all kinds of things a six is
weak everything is weak but there's no
plan no pieces to exploit that in fact
Black has won the d4 pawn very
importantly yep that's a very nice
position for black with that porn
however white has some play and now he
has regained one pawn
okay no white white is not in such bad
shape now
the problem is that the Queen on d5 is
very strong and black has very little
activity to show her it tough game for
Magnus that that he should lose I don't
see how it's going to pull off an upset
here it almost has to take and now how
do you stop the Queen c7 and promotion
probably you don't yeah even the knight
can capture No
yeah and Magnus resigned tough okay now
it's playing any reason the current
tournament leader is going forward
double hand keto yeah Knight age three
always kind of hoo-ha shot a little bit
and those moves I mean as a chess
teacher you like to see the world
champion play play good moves and not 9
Age 3 but okay it is a it is bullet
chess and you can do all kinds of funny
things yeah white is a lot better here
just d6 f5 would be should be
devastating
they're not there to a night is still
still pinned and cannot join join the
attack so it's a good defensive a black
not losing immediately can you not take
it what can you not take d5 I had to
check there okay but where's the win
we're suing now there wasn't doing yeah
amazing very cold-blooded very cool
blood very nice defense by earlier is I
mean it was certainly completed lost but
he did not simply fall apart
okay the two parts they are so dangerous
so cannot completely count Magnus out of
this yeah it's going to promote but
black is having the first a bunch of
checks Wow
yeah black has the initiative with all
the checks and he blundered the Queen
and he blow mr. Queen oh my goodness Wow
where they had a head time they had
seconds that that said stuff wow that's
a kind of Cicely action air you get in
the bullet game sometimes oh my goodness
okay so there was it was an important
win for the world champion but more than
more than lucky
again so we caught a lot of trades in
this game
magnets got paired with number 28 loeli
loeli relatively 2625 that's dangerous
Queen f6 em if black cannot trade Queens
quickly you will come under heavy
pressure there on the Kings side yeah
Brooke edge 127 is just about holding
but it does nicely defended it looks
like black is under huge pressure but
he's not cracking there wasn't a
sacrifice that was more of a blunder but
there is there is there is so trouble
for black you know looking at the rook
on d8 BAM there goes through crook h8
and black as checkmated yeah there was
an up and down game as well absolutely
up and down struggle so let me I want to
check the standings quickly Magnus is in
6th place
he's behind 13 points very very close
everything is very close yeah basically
it's any anybody's game him ok I'm going
to watch this game
seeing what penguin is doing okay so
he's given up Oh
given a VIPs for a million a million
points yeah and why why should why
should win but anything can happen of
course as we have seen ya know black
gets a vicious counter-attack here on
the long diagonal H takes G to winning
the house but King edge want is a
defense like is running out of material
very nicely played let's see six now
hanging it's still not super easy it's
still something you can definitely screw
up
you know White's King position is really
really problematic yeah so white has a
winning position now for sure but it's
got no time
yeah and lost on time wouldn't v-- my I
don't speak French
800 yeah there is no name in there I
mean if it's from France you if it's in
French account you're always suspected
that it's MBL but maybe maybe not him
okay let's see what penguin is doing
here caching caching it's playing this
video Penang in the whole time
Remo song okay is a 2600 GM I think
yeah maybe caching is what one is meant
by this account anyway so let's have a
look here Penguin has a good position
2600 I meant mr. Musa dumped like he is
clearly clearly better and he's got a
pawn on top of it no black hands
excellent control him and white has no
real plane that is that is a parent at
least more of a positional positional
game this one okay now there's a big
skewer and the root cannot move I mean
so there is a we know in exchange anyway
black it's not taking it this is a
always remarkable yeah you almost
automatically take the rook but he
didn't have to take it the whole time he
just wanted to do it at a better more
fitting moment it's still not it's not
easy the white pawn dam is a very strong
windy foul not easy for penguin but he's
got more time that is very important of
course okay no white is better but the
time is not great takes 96 yeah white
should win but okay it's the time in
penguin playing re-raise are the first
two places
now very very complicated position maybe
widest better if you do it like on
computer terms but and we already see
the combination see I'm coming okay
when black it's probably lost but it is
very complicated still the long diagonal
is quite a weak and now them the like is
trying trying for counter play but he is
not going to do it without the Queen
itself
okay so win by penguin let's have a look
I want to check the justice standing
quickly it is really again 15 points in
between Magnus and the tournament leader
really really tough but he has to he
still loses the odd game and he has to
get a winning streak rolling card and
asked him yeah he is definitely better
winning the d5 pawn and having gather
much better piece placement now I can
simply take play d5 and that that looks
like fairly clean clean win for the
world champion start working can take on
c5 probably no this is better it's nice
so now the check and the ending should
be winning is it winning it's not it's
not that easy
it's not that easy
maybe not even objectively a win the
b-pawn currently isn't worth all that
much I am that is not that's not a win
I'm not sure if what Blacky did was all
that great but it's probably a draw and
at the time I tricked ma just took the
f-pawn okay and now this will be if like
flagging game and it's so silly you know
but that is what happens in this time
control yeah white one on time it's of
course that dead draw but yeah it's what
it is if you don't want these situations
they have to avoid non increment bullet
it just happens
okay Baba Ramdev now okay I've got the
c3 society
mm yeah I'm very sure that leaches is
going to do a thorough check of all the
all the games and the tournament for
cheating there was a question in the
chat what is done in that by that regard
I don't know how exactly that works okay
so here this is a completely equal
position I know sometimes I wonder if it
is an idea simply to offer draw and get
and get on with it but Carlton is trying
to do something
hi there is a there is a message here by
niches moderator so they all watch this
very seriously for cheating like not
this game or anything a particularly
noble tournament of course okay this is
a total draw I mean does it make sense
to continue this Magnus is trying it
seems he's got more time on the clock
yeah and zero page three how do you stop
that now Luke age three the screen t6
chicken and he blunders chief one g4 was
hanging now so it should be a draw but
it's flag down again okay it's a tall
couldn't couldn't keep the porno on the
board
yeah I should have offered to draw at
the very beginning may not very
beginning at the beginning of this
completely dead position I don't know
so what happens here against Vallejo
pons sidelined in the Sicilian there
probably roughly equal dispersion yeah
I've got bishop against Knight and the
bishop is some looking like the stronger
piece at the moment but that could
definitely change if we get an ending
where the pawns are not mobile it is
symmetrical after on probably this it is
an equal position it's roughly equal I
think black will manage to trade off one
rook and then no nothing much happens
9f5 was an idea that was not really no
interesting interesting play abide by
Magnus what immediately returns us okay
and this is the speaking upon ending I
think twins from like because he would
get down outside person maybe not joking
F or maybe not c4 and black wins by
which is quicker right in those endings
it rarely happens that he makes any
mistake
yeah the screen ending coupons up is a
win and especially now and get it queen
king a queen ending ok and black winter
as it as it should be he was a better
the whole time and now playing macro
Fargo I don't know this I have to check
the standing we're nearing the end of
the tournament that we are 37 minutes
left
yeah this is the problem that comes to
c5 and black is completely lost
yeah Magnus is totally lost micro fog
we're doing a great job
Quincy a medium it's really tough
now that that should be when yeah Magnus
cannot afford to give give away games
like that where he is the favorite for
sure but they're all their own strong
players not not that is him so he is 15
points behind with 36 minutes to go and
yes to overtake all of them now that
seems tough the whole tournament is wide
open
it's really wide open so I'm going to
open some sorry watch some of the
neatest games here against penguin Ollie
realized still leading this event the
whole time
that's definitely true I mean I don't
agree that it is fair there's a camel
doc says in the chat that everybody
knows Magnus and gives 120% to win this
is definitely right yeah but this is the
case with every sport where you are just
an outstanding performer can be a team
or a single single player there's the
same thing in any team sports you know
if you are real madrid everybody gives
like 101 120 percent against you
but it's just what it is and they still
win I'm just making an example yeah I'm
not a particularly majority I know
anything if you are I know Roger Federer
our Tiger would some years ago where you
know that people give the absolute best
okay penguin wonders and it's super
super close absolutely
yeah if you're real Madrid you get a
free witness has some truth to that at
least that that game was a little bit
weird
again spoil anyway
so here Ali Riza is in trouble for sure
against wizard 98 the aged foul will be
dangerous very dangerous
Wow
what is defending he's really defending
black winter very nicely played here by
Ali Riza not like baby not directing
winning but it looks very close
I have no clue who's winning their
[Laughter]
wizard yes putting up a nice fight yeah
and he won he's still close to the lead
he is close to the lead the whole time
yeah Magnus is not gaining a winning
streak and you know he doesn't have
those force in this is super important
to get get the winning streaks rolling
yeah again a b3 based opening here for
for any reason and it's kind of easy to
play a position I guess thanks for the
chip now black has a nice play on that
or the long diagonal yeah this
tournament will have fun also the point
count for the top players will be lower
it's a much more open issue yeah I think
black is in quite quite a good shape
here probably the pressure on the long
diagonal the bishops
a nice job here by our comm but it's
still not straightforward we know
anything like that
no black is trying to put as much
pressure as possible and it looks very
dangerous
f5 was hanging now a very strong attack
here for black
Wow I'm kind of amazed that white is not
just falling apart but now we just yeah
very nicely done the black like all
power moves the penguin comes in first
at the mood and first again second again
playing they have already played a
couple of games they have played four
games today and penguin or this is the
fourth game penguin is currently leading
so we have a Ben Oni type of position
well yeah who's better here and why I
don't know black seems to be okay if you
ask me
yeah black black is okay he only has
this potentially quite a weak King
position that can always be an issue and
I was going to go 44 at some point and
get the Knight to e5 but first of all he
opens up a queen side okay now just
before maybe therefore I have all said
what's the idea okay quite that just a
mess em the apron is dangerous but the
white king can be a potential potential
ischium g3 hangs neither voice also move
just not played yeah now white is
getting the initiative here I think 95 I
expected 95 but it didn't happen so that
the Queen that the night gets finally
some activity
the rupee sama I think penguin should
win this one yeah and repeat 6m that was
nice that looked like a good job
well white so I'm keeping an eye on the
stand now I want to know if something
happens now Magnus is not not coming
here there it's not going to do that I
think one of the two I'm going to do it
earlier is our penguin I'm I'm with
penguin I think he will will do it so
let's see if he keeps on winning
yeah good position here by penguiny
against I'm not sure I'm going to try am
I
I have no know the ability whatsoever to
pronounce anything in French so wait
it's right yeah penguin is clearly
better against the French player here
with white Queen to b7 is going to be
the killer which is some are not played
okay there if you have a fork they are
then you just win yeah I know it nice
very nice job a black thanks for the
Chia Eric's yeah a knight King we
haven't heard of him right botnik is
very strong play actually but some are
not having a good event this time yeah
there can be all kinds of influences
first of all bullet as much it's a flow
thing if it if it kind of if you got
this flow going everything is is great
and sometimes you just don't get down
and things like connection quality and
technical issues that they are important
so we never know what what's happening
them yeah very good position here by the
way for penguin Jam he should be very
happy with this he's just got the center
and playing just a really nice
positional game being better d5 is
something that I would expect but this
this looks very strong as well yeah
those pieces but what is what has a
great attack okay no no lots of things
are traded huh a knight King is our
piece amazing he had here a rotten
position absolutely
yeah black is completely winning there's
a there's a discussion in the in the
chat about about if anybody else that
Magnus wins this tournament which is
very likely should they didn't donate
the money back for the next tournament
or not and I have a clear opinion they
should not donate absolutely not I mean
if they want to okay it's it's their
choice but I think they should
especially if it's one of the two guys
like penguin is I don't know in his late
teens and early Raisa is a young like
he's 14 15 they have good use for this
money and they they shouldn't donate it
my opinion it's their choice of course
but I mean like if I would win it I
would take it as well I mean just my
just my my opinion and I can't I'm just
too bad but just theoretically speaking
[Music]
so very a good position again here for
penguin against ali riza those games are
super important of course
this is not a position you want in a
bullet game the wide position I mean the
king is completely insecure I don't
think
I don't see a window in okay that's my
problem but flag seems to be in very
good shape I mean it's got two or three
pawns here for the for the piece what is
your writing like my writing I'm two to
four fifty and in classical chess my
Buddha T is also like to four fifty
it's up and down of course yeah we can
hear ali reza is defending he's
defending extremely well where now we've
got some some blunders but and penguin
is coming back and winning yeah I think
he's going to win that time I think oh
okay this is not so easy now that's one
no I don't have any grandmaster norms
thanks for asking I'm mostly playing for
fun nowadays do more writing and
teaching yeah it's a tough pairing yeah
for for Andrew ten he could have gotten
anybody and he gets Magnus of all people
and it's not a nice position to be in
because Magnus definitely has an attack
going here let's see what happens
now thanks for the feedback on my
commentary let if you enjoy it
everybody has their style of doing it I
mean they have been some good
computations in the first four editions
as well
yeah Magnus is better you despite being
the exchange down I think the f-pawn is
dangerous though the f-pawn is dangerous
maybe Magnus can just push the ape on
just push the ape on
he's up on the clock penguin is up on
the clock and Magnus is not finding
something decisive yeah that that's not
his tournament he can escape just about
escape to not getting checkmated
immediately but yeah you know the demos
there was a good choice and the points
too dangerous
but okay yeah there's an h-bomb
what a crazy position it's still not so
easy to do that Magnus's maybe winning
and I don't believe it him yes he wins
this I don't know you wanna lose on time
oh my god okay six yeah that's it that's
it problem let's check I it's just six
points in just six points
I mean Magnus is not going to do it but
penguin is close our super important
I was super fond claim
so what's going on here um playing my
master macro Fargo and he is a material
it's a it's a rook it's a full rook
actually not full yeah it's got pawns
but no play whatsoever so the penguin
should win this now yeah that should be
a relatively easy win for entertain yeah
and with the knight traded yeah yeah
penguin I am and the different username
already was in the lead in the fourth
edition and then Magnus got this
fantastic winning streak together and
maybe he's doing it now winning winning
this event finally in this particular
position I think black is okay here
wizard it's got this dangerous e pawn
even though what you have to take into
account the bishop on g7 is not playing
at all not at all well maybe white is
actually better it is still difficult
difficult to play
yeah now the deep on is getting quite
dangerous
oops what's going on here Queen f2i
please don't do it yeah somebody said if
Magnus winning is going to eat his cat
don't do that yeah it's not a good idea
eating cats for whatever reason you can
eat your head maybe yeah yeah don't
damage anything don't hurt anything
okay so op abysm here playing against
the penguin yeah that's pretty easily
equalized Jim it's a good position for
Blackie you know night only 4 is
dangerous 92 under on the cards but not
doing much right now okay yeah no no I
rather think white is okay is it a seven
hanging
[Music]
and a three-year I was thinking f3 and
yeah that's a piece f1 yeah it's not
technically all that simple but what is
a piece of ya that will probably be a
loss for lucky
yeah and operation wins this so what is
the standing 15 minutes in penguin is
leading by eight points yeah that will
be that will be enough I think
penguin has a clearly better position
against catching probably just taking
Andrew t3 is good but he might have
something better now and 94 as an idea
rocket e2 now threatening to win 94 is
an interesting move okay
he tries to do something simpler which
is probably also better now white is
just under pressure in the situation
here
it's got no active play on its own you
know takes Knight f4 we win the exchange
at least very good defense by white here
by the way that's the kind of position
that I would definitely we definitely
just lose but white is hanging on here
King f2y was king of two losing I didn't
see it but that's probably my problem
so now penguin is winning of course
being a queen up yeah white reside
oh honey Reza I said having a streak
yeah that that's going to be very close
let's see what he's doing against our
car 50 a moment black his under under
pressure but he's defending so so well
here black is just winning I think
White's position is falling completely
apart yeah 93 Quincy 4 is an easy way to
win I think probably something else
yeah like black should win but there are
so still issues it's not easy
maybe black can drum up a mating attack
like here it's clever Sam it's really
close rooks III no rook gd1 mate now is
the threat now that would be about the
time very nicely played by black though
yeah black movement early reserve
winders white has made ton of books
still at the end ok I'm going to check
again Magnus is coming a little bit but
that cannot be enough he's on streak but
Ali Ruiz is on streak as well I think
he's probably the favorite now oops
ok let's see what he does against gsv
seem relatively light pairing yeah
relatively this is all also a little bit
about nerves yeah for the other guys
infamous is absolutely
unemployment neighs if he pulls some
sort of upset it's cool but I mean for
those guys winning such a tournament is
great it's a lot of money and it's it's
also some prestige of course but 3,000
not bad night f2 wasn't that working ok
let's see what happens here
ten minutes left by the way yeah
White has lots of white has a pretty
substantial advantage okay
not anymore our black is a little bit
better but it's not not substantial okay
objectively it's a draw now maybe white
can do something with the two connected
pawns okay okay this is even I draw now
without the H parts okay this is a draw
this is a draw Magnus would probably
finished maybe third or something is
also credited Rho they all they all give
up points okay what happens here penguin
he lost this game I won't follow so he
doesn't get oh it's got really pared
down Wow
you know he's got a good position our
white screwed up the opening what I
think a little bit that's a pretty
decent position for black who's got some
space on the queenside
24 was a good ending for black but okay
didn't do it oh yeah how about this is
very nice for black now iam winning this
porn is a is a huge one
yeah that that should be a win for black
very important win also has got more
time hey let's say Gulen in Vegas
wouldn't need the $75 he wins for fifth
place yeah you should yeah ninety-seven
that's an issue but this is a good
defense good move yeah and a win for
penguin now playing ah pervasive let's
see race is soon in the lead of his he
but he lost the last one let's see what
happens here
he's up a lot on the clock actually and
also has a somewhat lower rated opponent
which is not does mean all that much
that's why I'm trying to save b7 okay
now he's winning I thought you would win
but it isn't the case really it's not
not that easy no no you should win still
threats on f2 name and you win on time
Wow yeah okay
whoa so yeah this is the game yeah not
sure how close they are but penguin
needs to win that's really all that
matters now
yeah maybe it draw for white is okay but
you cannot play for draw of course five
minutes left
you know black is clearly better in this
position very clearly better but why Jim
Ali Riza is a super tough defender we
have seen that he has saved some really
atrocious positions and again there is
put his night on good squares connected
it with the e5 square but nights of
tricky but black is better
very nicely played but black don't trade
twins you know the Queen's have to be on
the board I'm amazed about the level of
play is really great I mean they don't
blunder it all makes some sense you know
and White has his his piece tripped
himself out of it somehow
amazingly wide yeah such a tough
defender he now has the better ending
with the Knights and it's still not easy
well they're still Knights but a penguin
has better time and that still can
matter it's not a super easy win
Oh g7 and black is winning oh he's
winning this Wow Wow it will be very
close
what's the standing penguin now leading
by two points it's one of the two yeah
we know that yes sorry I'm following him
actually watch game give me the game
penguin if he wins it he's won the
tournament right three minutes left
why do you okay with ali riza might win
quickly that can happen oh that's not
mvl I don't think it's MVL yeah it's not
an easy drawing him absolutely not
yeah I think penguin looks like it's
better here but it's not easy at all
night on g6 looks dangerous but it
doesn't threaten all that much Anna now
46 that's going to be super dangerous is
six but black can play probably 95 oh
this is not going to be easy at all it
is blundered to look no he doesn't
sorry a super tough game for penguin 95
what the heck super tough game after
such a long tournament very very
complicated stuff
queen d3 looks dangerous and black is
just making a drawing okay what's
happening here so four points still are
they are going to be pairings actually I
have got penguin against arc I've got
one minute left
and a plate a draw
so no pairings anymore I don't know how
this works
Oh blundered the rook but okay it's
probably not important anymore as
penguin has basically has it in the back
I guess yeah the time has run out
and Dwight actually wanders so penguin
Jam wins at Andrew ten one-day event
congratulations to to Andrew who was
very very very close last time but
finished I think second place very close
to him and was caught by Magnus Carlsen
this time
he's winning the event in a very close
finish three points and he won this
crucial game against his opponent
aneurysm I have to check it again to not
completely screw up the name and here is
a fuchsia hopefully somewhat correct who
also played a fantastic event they were
both quite a bit ahead of third place
like 10 points that this is something
Magnus Carlsen world champion at the end
with 109 points 16 points behind yeah as
it seemed he had some connection issues
and was not probably able to play
addisam at his best still a fantastic
achievement by Andrew Teng the first
price was exactly $3,000 and in them the
first four events Magnus Carlsen was the
winner and donated this money back for
the next tournament I don't know what
will happen here I don't really expect
that to happen again
if he just takes the money it's
perfectly fine it of course yeah
3,000 bucks is not bad for two hours of
bullet chess I hope you all enjoyed the
livestream I was very happy to do it and
thanks to leeches for asking me doing it
if you liked it send some positive
feedback I'm happy to do it again for
the 6th edition or some other announcers
certainly also you're happy to do it I
think it's a it's really really a cool
event and great to cover thanks a lot to
all of you and bye-bye
you